I read the the conscience of
conservative by Goldwater and I guess he
didn't really write the book but he
approved it and it was a terrific read
it still is to this day and it did
influence me it made me a limited
government person a constitutionalist
and and from that you you know you you
get involved with people who agree with
you on those issues and learn from them
about Ludwig von Mises fa hayek I an R
and those I read all those people's
books and and became very much a
libertarian
I don't think that I was affected by the
what was actually going on in society so
much as I was attracted to the logic of
what he was saying that people should be
left alone and that the role of
government was to protect your rights to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and and I find that I found
that very compelling I ended up going to
Berkeley and saw you know kind of
attitude that the law didn't matter in
some of the sit-ins and and certainly
the riots and so forth and so that
reinforced my views but I've always
thought I was a libertarian I always
believed that there was no justification
for other people telling you how to live
your life and and subsequently learned
about the importance of private property
and the rule of law and so forth but I
think you know my father was a
conservative so I disagreed with him on
a lot of things my mother was a
political but I've always been a
libertarian
well I ran for student government at
Berkeley on a platform of abolishing the
student government and I thought that
was pretty radical but I actually lost
the election but those were theirs those
were tough tough years for those who
believe in less government on on the
Berkeley campus but and so I got
involved with the Goldwater campaign in
1964 I was a member of youth for
Goldwater at Berkeley which was a small
group and I actually was a precinct
captain for two precincts in berkeley
and I knew every single voter who was
going to vote for Barry Goldwater there
was a five in one district I think and
six in the other and it was you know but
I'd knock on everyone's door in the
precincts and the you know there were
for the most part civil to me but some
were hot a little hostile and then
goldwater's campaign itself disappointed
me he had originally said we need to
privatize Social Security and and then
backed away from it very shortly
thereafter and I thought it was I always
thought it was too hawkish about Vietnam
so I figured you know I'm out of
politics I'm a libertarian all there is
up there is the conservatives and
liberals and I don't buy into either
camp and so I was going to get out of it
and I went to work for Scudder Stevens
and Clark a investment firm and then was
my loyalty to Scudder ended when
Alliance capital offered to double my
salary and so I went to work for them
and and eventually I got involved with
the Libertarian Party there in 1971 the
Libertarian Party had its founding
convention at the radisson hotel in
denver colorado and i went to that and i
was i was like the only person with a
suit on and as a libertarian i always
knew was in
wooden to be tolerant of alternative
lifestyles but I always say it until I
went into that convention hall I had no
idea how many alternatives there were it
was it was a really weird it was like a
Star Wars bar scene they had you know
Randy ins with long cigarette holders
and gold bugs and anarchists and gay
rights activists and and and and some
hardcore conservatives who were still in
favor of the war in Vietnam but it was
an eclectic group and they all shared
this kind of commitment to liberty and I
found myself attracted to it and I went
back to California and flipped a coin
with a friend and lost and became the
vice chairman of the Libertarian Party
California had 12 districts I I
organized and drove all around the
southern part of the state and and and
got involved and then in 1974 I was
elected national chairman of the party
and I kind of ran it really threw 1980